Good morning Hank, it's Sunday,
June 28th 2009.
And I'm angry.
*John screams and whips his hair back and forth*
So Hank, as you know, in our two and a half year conversation,
we've now uploaded more than five hundred videos. Congratulations by the way,
and thanks to the awesomeness of Nerdfighters, our videos have been watched lots and lots of times.
But not everyone who's watching them is awesome.
So Hank, I'm gonna read you some comments that people have posted in the last week on Vlogbrothers videos.
These are all direct quotes, except for every time they use a curse word, I'm going to use the name -
- of a famous american poet.
'You Walt Whitman-ing Ednis-ing Vincent Mulet.'
'Go Emily Dickinson your mom!'
Thanks for the advice, you pathetic piece of E.E.Cummings.
But I think I'm gonna pass.
'You Robert Frosting Nikki Giovanni! Get a life nerd!'
'You're a virgin!'
*Screams of anguish and head rubbing intensifies*
'Hey bro, you need to go outside and get some fresh air into you, or a girlfriend."'
I need to get a girlfriend into me?
I think that shows a fundamental lack of comprehension about how babies are made.
'You are a complete Ann Sexton stupid!'
Okay, couple things, first off; if you're accusing someone of being stupid, you should probably -
know that in that context, 'you're' is a contraction, and any time you're contraction 'you are' -
it's spelled Y-O-U-APOSTROPHE-R-E!
OHMYGOD YOUTUBE! Before you click submit comment; read your comment and ask yourself -
do I mean ''You are"! And if you do, [whispers] you need and apostrophe.
Secondly, accusing someone else of being stupid, implies that you have the intellectual facility to
know the difference between stupid and smart! A case that is not bolstered when you use stupid as a noun!
'This video is so Ralph Waldo Emerson Gay.'
'You're gay'
'You're a gay nerd'
'Gay'
Okay YouTube, apparently we have to have a talk about this. Because you're obsessed with calling
things gay.
So I thought this was pretty wildly known but I guess I have to explain what gay means.
Being gay means that you are attracted to people of the same gender.
So a video can't be gay, because it doesn't have a gender.
Hank, I never thought I would have to do this but, I think I have to explain to YouTube how insults work.
When you're insulting someone, what you wanna do is you wanna make them feel bad about themselves.
So you wanna paint them with character traits or identities that are bad.
So for instance, Hank, if I wanted to hurt your feelings, I might say that you're a selfish coal-fired power plant.
But to read YouTube comments, you would think that the worst thing in the world to be is not a -
- selfish coal-fired power plant, but a gay virgin nerd.
We have this weird thing in the world where  you don't get insulted for what you do, you get
insulted for who you are.
And ultimately, 'gay' will never work as an insult, because it's not bad.
So you wanna call me a gay nerd virgin?
That's fine.
Believe me when I say, you are not embarrassing me. You are embarrassing yourself.
You wanna insult me? Take a lesson from this guy: 'You look kinda like that guy from Wild Hogs, lol'
Wha- What guy from Wild-?
Tim Allen?
I look like Tim Allen?
Wow Hank, that's a burn.
Nerdfighters, on Tuesday I'm gonna do a question Tuesday, so please leave great questions in comments.
Hank, I hope you're having fun with Mom and Dad and the Katherine, and you'll see me on Tuesday!